salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique depuis une dizaine
d'années une question hante la gauche et
cette question c'est comment gagner les
élections en effet entre l'éclatement
d'une partie de la gauche modérée vers
le maquereau nisme et la désertion des
classes populaires et ouvrières pour le
vote front national la gauche est à sec
de réservoir électoral et depuis 2010
est au moins elle ne pèse plus que 25% à
chaque élection est donc une question à
la vente qui est deux ou trouver de
nouvelles voies alors une réponse est
venue en 2011 du fameux rapport terra
nova qui conseillait au parti socialiste
de se détourner des questions sociales
et se tourner vers le sociétal pour
séduire à la fois les classes moyennes
les robots entre guillemets
et à la fois les classes pauvres issus
de l'immigration
également on a vu en 2010 est que jean
luc mélenchon pensait que les 600 mille
voix qui lui manquait pour être au
second tour se trouvait en fin de compte
dans les banlieues est donc cette
question du vote immigrés comme ruth
secours à une gauche qui est en train de
se déballonner est assez récurrent et ça
amène à poser une question existe-t-il
et à quoi ressemble notamment des
musulmans de gauche et bien pour
répondre à cette question on dispose
d'une étude qui alors qu'il ya quelques
années maintenant qui a été fait en 2014
par la fondation jean jaurès une une
étude qui portait sur les orientations
politiques de la population francilienne
donc c'est une étude qui ne vaut que
pour l'île de france mais qui tout de
même nous permet de dresser un portrait
de certains électeurs et ce qui est
intéressant avec cette étude c'est que
les réponses individuelles ont été
analysés pour être regroupés en cluster
en fonction est bien de patterns de
réponse et ainsi on a pu dégager
plusieurs groupes dont les réponses
étaient homogène au final la fondation
jean jaurès à trouver une demi douzaine
de groupes dont certains d'ailleurs
correspondent un peu à des stéréotypes
populaire puisque par exemple le groupe
d'aînés aux militants et bien correspond
à ce qu'on appelle classiquement les
bobos et parmi ces clusters il y en a un
qui est appelée neo traditionaliste dans
ce groupe d'aînés aux traditionalistes
vous avez une part extrêmement
importante de musulmans ce qui a fait
dire à gilles finchelstein le dirigeant
de la fondation jean jaurès qu'on avait
une photographie d'un groupe qu'on
pourrait appeler les musulmans de gauche
alors ce groupe d'aînés aux
traditionalistes est composé à 38 % de
musulmans ce qui est très important et
surtout ses 38 % de musulmans au sein de
ce cluster représente un musulman sur
deux de la région parisienne sachant que
ce groupe de néo traditionalistes
représente 12 % des franciliens en 2014
on peut d'ailleurs estimé qu'à ce moment
là il y avait au total aux alentours de
1,4 million de musulmans en région
parisienne alors ces néo
traditionalistes d'un point de vue
social ce sont des gens relativement
pauvres qui sont aussi très jeune par
rapport au reste de la population d'île
de france 52% à moins de 35 ans contre
31% seulement dans la population d'île
de france en général également vous avez
un taux ouvriers et employés supérieurs
à la moyenne d'île de france et puis
autres indicateurs sociaux ce sont des
gens qui sont relativement précaire de
haut niveau de leur emploi et puis les
revenus c'est la même chose ils sont
beaucoup plus faibles que le reste des
franciliens également autres grands
indicateurs de précarité une très grande
partie de ces personnes dites nez aux
traditionalistes vivent dans des
quartiers hlm pour un quart d'entre eux
est globalement habitent dans des zones
d'habitation assez pauvre largement plus
que le reste des franciliens donc d'un
point de vue social dans ce cluster on a
des personnes qui sont extrêmement
pauvres par rapport au reste des
franciliens pour ce qui est de leur
rapport à la politique on a des gens qui
effectivement semble être de gauche
quand on leur demande si l'état doit
assurer les besoins de chacun ou si cela
repose sur la liberté et la
responsabilité individuelle
ils sont 51% à pencher pour l'état quand
on leur demande si l'état doit encadrer
l'activité économique des entreprises là
ils sont 73% à répondre oui contre
seulement 48 % des franciliens et quand
on leur demande et bien si la justice
sociale doit passer par l'état et
doit être une politique de robin des
bois de prendre aux riches pour donner
aux pauvres ils sont 75% à répondre oui
donc au niveau du social ils sont
effectivement de gauche pour ce qui est
des valeurs également peut noter
beaucoup d'accointances avec avec la
gauche puisque ils sont 80 % à estimer
bien que les immigrés sont une source
d'enrichissement culturel pour la france
et dans ce cluster on a également 82%
des dénés aux traditionalistes qui sont
pour le vote des étrangers et de fait
dans les urnes ce tropisme de gauche se
traduit par un vote effectivement pour
les candidats de gauche malgré une forte
abstention dans ce cluster 20 % ont voté
pour jean luc mélenchon en 2012 ce qui
est largement au dessus de la moyenne en
région parisienne globalement la région
parisienne n'est pas la région la plus
fan de jean luc mélenchon et ils sont
même 49% avoir voté hollande au second
tour et ce malgré donc leur forte
abstention donc jusqu'ici on a des gens
qui effectivement correspondent à un
petit peu à l'électeur de gauche idéal
c'est à dire issus de classes
relativement pauvre et avec bien des
valeurs morales et sociales qui
correspondent à cette gauche et pourtant
sur certaines questions on a des
surprises puisque pour tout ce qui est
des questions de moeurs eh bien on voit
qu'on a là par contre un fort décalage
avec avec la gauche puisque ces néo
traditionalistes sont très conservateurs
quand on leur demande à la place de la
femme ils sont 65% a à nous dire que la
femme doit avant tout et bien élever les
enfants également ils sont contre
l'avortement à 45% et puis quand on
passe aux questions plus sociétale là on
atteint quasi unanimité est un vrai
décalage avec le reste de la population
puisque quand on demande et bien si
l'homosexualité est une façon convenable
de vivre sa sexualité ils sont 83% à
répondre non contre 17 % des franciliens
et quand on leur demande si ils pensent
que les homosexuels doivent pouvoir
adopter ils sont 95 % à répondre non
donc une population extrêmement
conservatrice d'un point de vue sociétal
et au final ces musulmans de gauche sont
certes intéressé par les questions
sociales notamment en raison de leur
niveau de vie ils sont aussi sur les
questions sociétales extrêmement
conservateur voire même réac
et de fait s'il était d'origine
européenne et de culture chrétienne et
bien la gauche qui les draguent cette
même gauche les très très probablement
de facho ou de réac
autre élément intéressant ces musulmans
de gauche ont un profil qui ressemble un
petit peu aux anciens électeurs du parti
communiste à savoir des gens issus des
classes populaires qui s'intéressent aux
questions à sociale mais qui par contre
sur les moeurs sont extrêmement
conservateur la famille c'est un papa
une maman le papa à l' usine et la maman
à la cuisine d'ailleurs on à fabien
roussel le candidat communiste là en
2022 qui nous fait un peu un retour aux
sources de cette gauche sociale et un
petit peu franchouillarde et ils ne
manquent pas de se faire traiter de
facho justement par cette gauche post
moderne notamment venant de de la france
insoumise et il est assez amusant de
voir la france insoumise quelque part
dragué ce genre d lectorat est de passer
sous silence et bien tout ce côté
sociétalement un petit peu conservateur
ou réac et le justifier quelque part
bien par le côté un côté essentialiste
ou exotiques c'est leur culture c'est
comme ça alors que des gens de culture
européenne et bien toujours de position
ne passerai absolument pas mais les voix
de l'électoralisme sont impénétrables
j'ai envie de dire bref j'espère que
cette courte vidéo vous aura intéressé
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à la
partager et à vous abonner à la chaîne
est sûre ça eh bien je dis à la
prochaine